I can't believe this is really happening
given the greatest opportunity any man
in this world could possibly have so
right off the bat in the first episode
Chris Harrison told these girls there
are no rules this year
how do you feel like that changed the
game and did it scare you knowing that
these wowed women were like yes no rules
yeah it's kind of like okay if there's
no rules what should I expect out of
this whole entire season being just 200
feet away from the mansion it's gonna be
a fun experience I'm excited too excited
to watch it all play out we're seeing
some pretty almost crazy moments and
play out on TV what were some moments
that you never knew were happening until
you watch back the show obviously Jordan
twerking listen what's new to me that
was interesting
did you know that the girls rummaged
through your place yeah I did they
actually left a note so I knew that they
I didn't know what they had done I
didn't know that they were walking
around banging their heads into
frigerators and brick walls with my
helmet but I did know that they came and
they left a sweet note for me you get to
kind of see the more Cattier side of
women through my date watching these
episodes back do you feel like if you
had heard these things during the
decision-making process it might have
changed your decisions at all good
question I think that right now I feel
like everything is playing out and what
I'm seeing and I don't feel like I have
any regrets for the most part I mean I
could have made some bad decisions I
mean and still not know it you know yeah
there was a lot of great women and and
aside from some of the cattiness or
whatever I mean that's some smooth
things happen but right now I think that
I feel like I've I'm pretty happy with
what I've handled things so far
unfortunately I feel like
I just don't feel like we have
that chemistry right now now The
Bachelor is known for these lavish and
gorgeous states and really creative
things you guys get to do together and
when these girls are an odd do you
almost feel bad taking credit for these
amazing dates you know it's it's
something that that we're both going
through together and experiencing
together it feels good to be able to
share that experience I'm as much in awe
as they are you know to a certain extent
it's nice to see them just smile and
have fun with it and you know because
it's a once-in-a-lifetime experience
you're in that moment thinking that you
could be spending that moment with your
future wife so it's pretty cool